ومن امام مقر لقاء وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن مع الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
هرتسوغ نظم اسرائيليون وقفه احتجاجيه
للمطالبه بالافراج عن ذويهم المحتجزين في
غزه والان من امام وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه في تل ابيب مراسلتنا فاطمه
خمايسي فاطمه اعتدنا رؤيتك بالخوذه
والستره وانت في الغلاف ولكن في غلاف غزه
هذه اول مره نتعرف عليك هكذا تفضلي ضعي في
صوره ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه من هذه
الزياره لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه لتلبي
تفضلي نعم ليله يعني بالرغم من انني لا
ارتدي الخوذه والدرع ولكن الجو محتدم هنا
على مستوى الشارع الاسرائيلي وفق بيان
ديوان رئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن
بدء اللقاء الذي يجري ما بين وزير الخارج
الامريكي انوني بلينكن مع رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو وهنا اذا ما اردنا ان
نرصد الاجواء نستطيع ان نرى احتدام على
مستوى الشارع الاسرائيلي ما بين اشخاص
يعارضون الحرب على غزه ويطالبون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالذهاب الى اتفاقيه لاطلاق
سراح الاسرى الاسرائيلي المحتجزين في غزه
وايضا ما بين مجموعه من الاسرائيليين من
سكان غلاف غزه تم اجلائهم الى منطقه مركز
اسرا تحديدا الى مدينه تل ابيب نحن نتحدث
عن تنظيم مظاهرات ونقاط احتجاجيه في هذه
الاجتماعات التي يجريها بلينكن مع عدد من
الاسرائيليين سبق وان تظار عشرات
الاسرائيليين صباح هذا اليوم امام الفندق
الذي التقى فيه بلينكن مع الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتسوغ وايضا مع نظيره
ح رائل كاتس هذا وزير الخارجيه الجديد
الاسرائيلي تعرف عليها اليوم بلينكن واكد
امامه مجددا ضروره ادخال المساع دات
الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه واعرب ايضا عن قلق
الاداره الامريكيه من كارثه انسانيه
محتمله في القطاع وان على اهالي ال سكان
شمال غزه العوده الى منازلهم والضغط على
اجراء عمليات عسكريه موضعيه ومحدده اكثر
وتغيير الحرب بالشكل الذي هي عليه طبعا
هنالك ايضا مظاهرات كانت صراحها هذا اليوم
بالطريق الى معبر كرم ابو سالم عندما تم
ادخال عدد من شاحنات المساعدات الغذائيه
الى والانسانيه الى قطاع غزه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه منعت عشرات الاسرائيليين من
عرقله ايصال هذه المساعدات بعض عائلات
المختطفين الاسرائيليين الاسرى تحديدا
يقولون بانه يجب وقف الحرب على غزه والضغط
على حركه حماس عبر ايقاف المساعدات
الانسانيه بمختلف انواعها وبالتالي يتم
الضغط على الحركه من اجل التوصل الى
اتفاقيه جديده لاطلاق صراح الاسراء
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه وايضا يتم
وقف اطلاق يتم وقف الحرب على غزه طبعا
شاهدنا نتائج العمليه العسكريه وايضا
العمليه الاخيره التي حاول الجيش
الاسرائيلي من خلالها اطلاق سراح الاسرى
عبر ارسال وحدات خاصه ولكن هذه العمليه
باءت في الفشل وتم الاعلان عن مقتله اربع
اربعه جنود وضباط امس وايضا كان
هنالك عمليه اخرى والتي اودت بحياه ثلاثه
اسرى
اسرائيليين حاولوا فروا من الحجز والاسر
في قطاع غزه والنيران الاسرائيليه قامت
بقتلهم وبالتالي هذا يزيد من استياء
الاسرائيليين يدفع بالشارع الاسرائيلي
بالنزول الى الشوارع وكما نشاهد يعني هنا
عدد قليل فقط يتظاهر الان ولكن هنالك اي
يجري تنظيم مظاهرات اكبر وفي مناطق حيويه
اكثر في ساعات مساء هذا اليوم طبعا لقاءات
بلينكن مع عدد من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
لا تزال قائمه نتحدث عن لقاء الان في
بنيامين نتنياهو ومن ثم سيلتقي اعضاء مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي وبعدها سيلتقي ايضا
بانفراد بيني جانس العضو في مجلس الحرب
ومن ثم ايضا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وبعدها سوف يدلي بتصريحات صحفيه هذه هي
الزياره الخامسه لوزير الخارجيه انتوني
بلينكن هنالك قلق من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه لسير المعارك سواء في الجبهه
الشماليه وايضا في الجبهه الجنوبيه وهنالك
محاوله للضغط على اسرائيل بان تقوم بتوقيف
هذه الحرب بشكلها الحالي وهذا ما انعكس
ايضا في تصريحات وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يوم امس يوف جلنت والذي قال ان اسرائيل
على ما يبدو سوف تنتقل الى المرحله
الثالثه من حملتها العسكريه على قطاع غزه
ومن حربها وبالتالي سوف تتغير شكل الحرب
الذي عليه ولكن هنالك قلق اخر الا وهو
الجبهه الشماليه بلينكن يريد من اسرائيل
ان تضبط الامور وعدم فتح جبهه اخرى مع
لبنان وبالتالي هنالك وساطات جدا كبيره في
هذا الامر سواء على مستوى الاداره
الامريكيه وايضا على مستوى الوساطه
الفرنسيه بما يخص المواجهه مع حزب الله
والتي بدت اشد
احتداماً حزب اللكود وقال ان علينا ان نته
باعاده سكان الغلاف ولكن هذا لا يعني ان
انه لن يكون هنالك عمليات لاطلاق الصواريخ
وبالتالي هذا اثار استياء سكان الغلاف
ودفعهم لتنظيم مظاهره مساء هذا اليوم
للمطالبه بمواصله هذه الحرب على غ اشكرك
اشكرك فاطمه على كل هذه المعلومات